(Singing) I am an endangered species
(Applause and cheers)
But I sing no victim song.
I am a woman.
I am an artist.
And I know
where my voice ...
belongs.
(Applause and cheers)
Now, you might have heard
me sing that song.
It was September 12th, 2022,
right after Amy Poehler
and Seth Meyers said,
"And the winner is,
Sheryl Lee Ralph!"
What!?
I had just won the Emmy Award
for Best Supporting Actress in a comedy
for my role as Mrs. Barbara Howard
on your favorite TV show,
"Abbott Elementary."
(Cheers)
Oh, yes.
And I was shocked.
As the children would say,
shooketh into disbelief.
Oh, my goodness, it was my first time
at the Emmys and I won.
Yes!
And I got to tell you,
in that moment,
I was so stunned into disbelief
that I don't know
how I got up on the stage.
There I was, just listening
to that roar of applause.
Mm mm mm.
And my whole career flashed
right there in front of me.
Starting with 19-year-old Sheryl Lee
in her first movie
being directed
by the great Sidney Poitier.
Oh, yeah, you can clap that.
(Applause)
Followed by ten years
of “no” after “no” after “no.”
Before the next film role came about.
But I filled in that time with TV
and more "nos" and more rejection
until I made it big on Broadway
in what has become
the iconic musical of the '80s,
because I say so,
(Laughter)
"Dreamgirls."
(Applause)
And boy, did I learn a lot
of life lessons there.
And I mean, after so many
moments of doubt, disbelief,
there I was, on that Emmy stage,
with this huge sign
in front of me flashing
"Stop now," "Stop now," "Stop now."
And I started to think,
“My God, what if I had stopped
after all of those ‘nos?’
What if I had stopped after all of those
moments of feeling defeated?
What if I had stopped?"
I wouldn't be standing there
for that golden moment.
But right now,
many of us, we are feeling ...
deeply challenged
trying to hold on
and believe in ourselves,
and I do not mean in a toxic way.
I am talking about a way
that comes from confidence,
the kind of confidence
that can keep us moving forward
when we are feeling
like we are carrying
the weight of the pandemic,
trying to figure out
all of this political division,
fighting all of the mental, physical,
social violence in our homes,
in our communities,
to climate change, social media.
It's a lot.
Making it hard to believe
in the goodness in the world.
And harder still to believe
in the goodness of ourselves.
This is a rough time, people,
and our mental health is suffering.
We all need a checkup from the neck up.
(Laughter)
And I don't mean -- yeah, it's OK.
You feel me, thank you.
(Applause)
And I don't mean just medicine.
I actually mean reframing our thinking
of our ability to believe in ourselves.
Now I know,
you see me on TV, in magazines,
on movie screens,
and you might be thinking to yourself,
"What does she know about struggling
to believe in herself?"
Well, let me tell you something.
I do not look like my journey.
(Laughter)
(Applause)
Oh, I've been through a few things.
And the struggle is real.
But I have learned something in my life.
That there are three things
that we all must do
in order to believe in ourselves.
Number one.
First, we need to see ourselves.
I mean, really, truly,
deeply see ourselves
for who and what we are
in order to believe in ourselves.
I’m a child of the ’60s,
and that was hard.
Oh.
In the third grade,
I tested out of public school
into a fancy private school
where the only Black person
I saw every day
was the one who looked back
at me in the mirror.
I was by myself, and I was all alone.
And the things that were said to me,
and I'm not talking about just the kids,
but the adults, too.
And when I would come home
from school crying the ugly cry,
my immigrant Jamaican mother
would sit me down in front of the mirror
and ask me,
"Do you see an N-word?
Do you see a liar?
Do you see a big-lip monkey?
No!
So dry your eyes.
And when you go back to school, remember,
you are rubber,
they are glue.
And every ignorant thing
they say about you
bounces off of you and sticks to them."
(Applause)
And I believed her.
And it didn't hurt.
So much.
Because I believed.
Number two.
We've got to think.
Think about ourselves
in order to believe in ourselves.
Growing up, my dad had a sign on his desk.
And it said, "Think."
"Think."
Oh, I did not know
how valuable and powerful
the simple act of thinking was
until I came back to Hollywood
from my triumphant run on Broadway,
and I had this meeting with a big studio
Hollywood casting director.
Oh, I was so excited.
I walked in and he looked
at me and he said,
"Hm.
Everybody knows you're a beautiful,
talented Black girl.
But what do I do with a beautiful,
talented Black girl?
Do I put you in a movie with Tom Cruise?
Does he kiss you? Ugh.
Who goes to see that movie?"
(Laughs)
I could not believe
that that man had just said that
to me, to my face.
And he hurt me.
He hurt me so deeply,
I was actually thinking about quitting.
Until ...
I started to think.
And I thought about what he said.
He said that everybody knew
that I was a beautiful,
talented Black girl.
(Laughter)
(Cheers and applause)
And that I deserve to be cast in movies
with the likes of Tom Cruise,
and he should kiss me.
(Applause)
(Laughs)
So what was meant to break me
did not break me, it built me up.
I believed that man,
I believed what he said.
And I walked out of there giving myself
permission to take up space in Hollywood,
knowing that I belonged there
no matter what anybody thought about me.
(Cheers and applause)
Thirdly.
We've got to act
like we believe in ourselves.
Oh, yeah.
Because when we believe
in ourselves and act on it,
we create possibilities
that never would have been possible
had we not just believed.
OK, so I will tell you another story.
I will never forget walking into one
of those crowded Hollywood rooms,
and I see Harry Thomason,
producer Harry Thomason,
who is married to Linda
Bloodworth-Thomason,
writer, creator of the series
"Designing Women."
I walk right up to Harry and I say,
"How can it be,
that after all of these years
Anthony has not had
a relationship with a Black woman?
After all, the show
takes place in Atlanta,
Georgia."
(Laughter)
He looked at me, took a step back
and said, "Who are you?"
I said, "I'm Sheryl Lee Ralph."
And he said, "OK.
Have your people call my people
and we will see what we can do."
And guess what happened?
(Laughter)
I got cast as Etienne Toussaint Bouvier,
Las Vegas showgirl turned Anthony's wife
for the final season of "Designing Women."
(Cheers and applause)
Oh, yeah.
Against all odds, once again,
I gave myself permission to take up space,
believing that I belonged.
I believed that if Sheryl Lee
did the work of honing her craft,
building solid relationships
and stayed ready
so she didn't have to get ready,
anything was possible.
Heck, winning an Emmy.
A Grammy.
An Oscar.
A Tony.
EGOT it, baby.
(Cheering)
So ...
When you leave this room today,
I challenge all of you
to start a meaningful practice
of looking in the mirror
and loving what you see.
Believe in what you see.
If you can't love it, then respect it.
And if you can't respect it,
then encourage it.
If you can't encourage it, empower it.
And if you can't empower it,
please be kind to it.
(Applause)
The greatest relationship,
the greatest one you will ever have
is with yourself.
Believe me.
Have faith in yourself.
Believing that faith
can make broken wings fly.
And we deserve to soar.
Remember,
maybe one of these days
when you pass the mirror
and you catch a glimpse of yourself,
remember, I told you this.
That is what believing looks like.
And don't you ever, ever,
ever give up on you.
I am Sheryl Lee Ralph,
and I love you just the way you are.
(Singing) Believe in yourself
As I believe in you
Thank you.
(Cheers and applause)